hi everybody we're back
even wright coming up in uh just a few
minutes very excited to see him
and uh i'm just curious though it is a
friday night and uh we're in the home
stretch
just curious max what are you uh gonna
do this weekend well conor my wife and
kids are out of town on sunday
so i'm having some of the guys over to
watch a giants game drink some beers you
know
order in some pizza hey why don't you
come by conan you know maybe around
three o'clock
three o'clock sunday yeah i could i
think i could do that yeah maybe i'll do
that
excuse me conan does that mean you're
canceling the regular meeting of our
sunday book club
oh hey paula no i
i didn't realize you were you were
sitting in the audience tonight yeah
yeah terry's here too
hi we were all looking forward to
discussing passion's promise by daniel
steele
oh is is that what we were supposed to
read this week because i thought we were
discussing some kind of
spy book like the bourne identity or
one of those books about sports
what are you talking about you picked
this book yeah
you said it was the only book that ever
made you cry harder the second time you
read it
well conan i wouldn't want to interrupt
your danielle steel
weep fest no max it's it's fine i'm
gonna be at your house i'll be there
it's okay conan why don't you watch the
football game and i'll run the book club
meeting this week
oh you'd like that wouldn't you terry
guess when the cat's away the mice all
play is that the deal
well why do you always get to pick the
books like last month when you made us
read the sisterhood of the traveling
pants
this is a book for pre-teen girls okay i
believe the correct classification is
young adult
and don't tell me you haven't dreamed of
a magic pair of jeans that fit your
curves just right
i just think it's time we read something
besides sentimental chicklet
okay is that what you think paula well i
i don't know i mean i don't want to get
in okay he's fine terry
you picked the books then we can meet at
your house and you can serve your
store-bought pasta salad and
eight-dollar chardonnay
well it's better than your cottage
cheese celery sticks and flat ginger ale
oh yeah
eight dollar chardonnay flat ginger ale
no wonder your husband left you
you heartless [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] one to no one stop it everybody
stop but the club is breaking up that
the club is pranking you okay no it is
not
here's what's gonna happen okay max i'll
go and watch the game with you
then i'll come back and we'll have a
meeting of my book club at my house at
eight o'clock
eight o'clock conan that mean you're
gonna cancel our leather orgy
i guess it does i'll still be there
i took it back to be right back stephen
wright